>> We'll have more on this
crisis as I mentioned coming up
later in the show including our
interview with general Kellogg
we begin today. With
an editorial by the Washington
Post. And just quickly
a note on newspaper lingo
and lexicon there pads or
columns in a newspaper op ed
are often from outside sources,
someone has written a piece
columns generally come from a
stable of columnists who work
at the newspaper. Then there
are editorials which is the
official position of the
newspaper and the editorial
board collectively. This isn't
about to read from is
an editorial. This is the
official view of the Washington
Post's editorial board. I saw
the headline. And my jaw drop
it is like satire.
There's gaslighting and then
there's this from the
Washington Post it's as if they
want to advertise to the
country. Dear America pay us
no attention pay us know he'd.
We are not to be trusted.
We are not serious people
and this is why our credibility
is in the toilet ready for this
headline.
Republicans boast they have not
pulled a Kavanaugh talking
about the current Supreme Court
hearings that wrapped up today
in fact they've treated Jackson
worse.
It is the position of the
Washington Post. That
Republicans this week. Have
treated Judge Jackson,
worse. Then Democrats treated
Brett Kavanaugh in 2018.
Now I was alive.
And conscious in 2018 as were
most of you.
And this
is certain bears absolutely no
resemblance to reality. It is
fantasy.
Gaslighting on steroids.
Here's part of what they write
the editors.
Of Washington Post throughout
her Senate confirmation
hearings judge cut Angie Brown
Jackson has been a model of
composure which is made all the
more impressive by the
egregious behavior of some of
the Republican side.
We can argue about whether the
behavior from some Republicans
amounts to agree just. I have
disagreed with some of their
lines of argument.
I think some of this is
showboating and grandstanding
which you always see in
hearings like this.
But to pretend as some insist
upon.
That this week was somehow out
of bounds or beyond the pale
are really awful.
Compared to how things normally
go is just simply.
Back to the editorial during
the hearings Republicans such
as senator Lindsey Graham
have congratulate themselves
for declining to treat Judge
Jackson the way Democrats
handled the nomination of Brett
Kavanaugh in fact by the most
relevant measures.
Mister Graham and a handful of
other judiciary Republicans
have handled themselves worse.
A woman credibly accused Mister
Kavanaugh of sexual assault.
Let's pause on that for a she
did. Doctor
blasey Ford made an allegation.
Credibility is contingent upon
evidence. There was
no evidence there is
no evidence in fact there is
precisely the same amount of
evidence. That Judge cut Angie
Brown Jackson. Was
engaged in an attempted sexual
assault has there ever was or
is that Brett Kavanaugh did
anything of the sort which is
to say none.
An allegation is not evidence
credibility must be backed up
with proof evidence
contemporaneous or otherwise
and there is none.
Backing any of the claims that
were made
against Brett Kavanaugh had
more to say about that in a
moment since they continue to
insist on lying.
About what happened in 2018
lying about that case lying
about Kavanaugh lying about the
evidence they will not let it
go and for that reason neither
will we we will fact check them
into oblivion for the rest
at least speaking on my own
behalf for the rest of my life.
If they demand to continue with
their lies.
And the Washington Post
editorial board front and
center.
Because it wasn't just
Democratic activists and
Democrats in the Senate it was
a lot of people in the media
journalists who were part of
that mob. Against Kavanaugh.
Actively participating in it or
cheering it on rooting it on.
And now people who are in the
mob are trying to tell the rest
of No. That wasn't so bad which
really bad as what happened
this week. To judge Jackson.
So they write a woman credibly
accused Mister Kavanaugh of
sexual assault, no evidence.
Democrats they write. Rightly
asked the committee
to investigate. I'll remind you
that this allegation was not
deemed credible by the
chairwoman at the time Dianne
Feinstein she did not see that
it was relevant to bring up in
the hearings even in closed
session. Then some left wing
activists working with their
partners. Staffers on the
committee on the Democratic
side. They drop these
allegations like a bombshell
after the hearings were over.
In a very cheap trick stunt.
A very dirty play.
Washington is like oh they
just they just asked some
questions they just wanted to
investigate. After a
superficial FBI review. This is
what the editorial claims a
superficial FBI review.
This is one of multiple FBI
background checks of Brett
Kavanaugh.
I believe was 6 or 7 over the
course of his career.
They wanted another review,
they got one and the
only thing that the FBI review
found in terms of new
information was that glossy
forwards dear friend at the
time and her top witness.
Told the FBI that she was
pressured to lie to hurt
Brett Kavanaugh by the
accuser's allies.
She said she and all the other
supposed witnesses that this
alleged party, none of them
said the party happened.
None of them backed up the
claims she said. That they
never seen but they made sense
to her.
And she has since told
reporters this is the friend
Leland Keyser that she does not
believe her friend Christine
blasey Ford she does not
believe the story. No element
of it is true and her allies
were bullying her behind the
scenes to get her to lie.
To exaggerate.
To purge or herself potentially
in order to achieve a political
end against Kavanaugh which
blasey Ford's own lawyer
admitted later, this was about
abortion jurisprudence they had
political motives.
So that's what the FBI
investigation actually found.
It was bad information for the
accusations which is why
they're pretending that it
really was just superficial and
didn't achieve anything.
Does it hurt the cause of the
mob.
The Washington Post
editors right. It was Mister
Kavanaugh who behaved
intemperate Lee.
He raised his voice he got
emotional, you know why he's
being accused in front of the
world of being
not just an attempted sexual
assailant in high school for
which there is no evidence but
also a gang rapist, a serial
gang rapist. That is what his
wife was being dragged through
and his kids.
This lunatic woman came out of
nowhere and said that Kavanaugh
was doing gang rapes in the
suburbs of D C.
Her story was
completely false totally fell
apart.
She was represented by Michael
avenatti who is now in prison.
There was not a shred.
To support this insane.
Psychotic claim against
Brett Kavanaugh and yet at
the time. Just after Julie
swetnick and Michael avenatti
trotted out this. Just
defamatory smear.
And she did perjured herself on
this.
Completely unraveled I will
remind you. It
was debunked it was a giant
disgusting lie. But Senate
Democrats on that committee all
wrote a letter that day saying
because of this in fact I can
quote.
Following the release of a
sworn affidavit from Julie
swetnick detailing new
allegations of sexual assault
by Brett Kavanaugh
all 10 Democratic members of
the Senate Judiciary Committee
today urge president Trump to
immediately withdraw the
nomination, Chuck Schumer
joining this insistence.
He joined the demand so you had
every Democrat on that
committee.
Who had the goal this week to
talk about comportment in
civility and norms are you
kidding.
Plus Schumer their leader in
the Senate. All seized upon the
gang rape fantasy.
From this
crazy person and her now felon
lawyer. As a reason for
Kavanaugh to withdraw.
But the real problem was Brett
Kavanaugh. Behaving intemperate
Lee.
When people were accusing him
on the record of gang rape.
By contrast. This
is the Washington
Post again. Republicans have
smeared Judge Jackson based on
obvious distortions of her
record and the law. We've
actually talked about some of
this I think some of the
criticisms and attacks in lines
of inquiry
were misleading I would not
have endorsed or embraced some
of the things that Republicans
did but at least they were
talking about her actual
record.
They were talking about her
behavior her conduct her
decisions as a judge as a
lawyer within the realm of
Criminal Justice they were not
talking about her high school
drinking habits. They're not
asking him when she lost her
virginity. They were asking her
that.
They were asking about drinking
games. They were
talking about her participation
in conjured out of nothing gang
rapes.
But it's the Republican
questioning this week that the
Washington Post says that's
really a bridge too far with
these disgraceful Republicans
worse than Kavanaugh worse.
What an insult. These people
think we have no memory these
people think we are morons.
The editorial concludes neither
side is blameless in the
politicizing of the
confirmation process but
particularly after they iced
out then judge Merrick Garland
in 2016. Republicans have done
the most damage.
I could do an entire hour and
in fact I have years ago on
this show. Completely
refuting that it is Democrats
who have ratcheted up. This
blood sport. On judicial
confirmations for decades.
Starting with Bork through the
Clarence Thomas, all the way to
Kavanagh. They
escalate unilaterally time and
time again. The
blockade of Merrick Garland was
using a Democrat advocated
tactic.
With lots of obstruction that
the Democrats pioneered
themselves.
And these tendentious
ideologues.
Who have no respect for the
facts or the collective
intelligence of the American
people at the Washington Post
want us to believe that the
Republicans are the aggressors.
I've done the most damage.
When it comes to the way
that these confirmation battles
play out wrong.
And that what we just witnessed
over the last few days was
worse than what the Democrats
and their allies dead. A few
years ago did. Now justice
Brett Kavanaugh.
Of garbage.
And I want to go down memory
lane with you. And just play
some sound. From 2018 not that
long ago. We remember it.
It does not compare to anything
that happened this week.
And we will get to some of
those sound bites as soon as
>> Look I want to say this will
help put up all put up her
credibility against Donald
Trump's our Brett kavanaugh's
any day of the week, I mean all
of these women cannot be lying,
I mean how many women are we up
to now that are accusing Brett
Kavanaugh of inappropriate.
Conduct.
>> I'm guy Benson that was
Michael avenatti on CNN with
Chris Cuomo isn't that fun.
Back in 2018 saying he would
put his clients. Credibility up
against Brett kavanaugh's any
day of the week. Well how's
that working out.
Has been 100% discredited.
She was lying about the
gang rape. And all the
Democrats on the Judiciary
Committee embrace that smear.
And used it to call on
Kavanaugh to withdraw.
Is a sitting associate justice
on the United States Supreme
Court.
And Michael avenatti is a
convicted felon sitting in
prison.
Cory Booker cut
15 during the Kavanaugh mess.
>> I knowingly violated.
The rules were
put forth I understand that
that the penalty comes with
potential ousting from the
Senate I'm saying I'm knowingly
violating the rules gay Centre
court only time or how many
times you tell us arrived
yesterday, I broke
these sham committee
confidential rules by accept
full responsibility for what
I'm doing.
>> Absolute clown.
He couldn't Bragg enough about
how he was breaking the rules.
Signal resistance against
Brett Kavanaugh number the
Washington Post tells us.
What Republicans did this week
far worse.
Kamala Harris then a senator
interrupted the first sentence
of the hearing. From chairman
Grassley started demanding all
sorts of you know
calls to order an opportunity
to ask questions interrupting.
Grassley,
there were protesters screaming
and shrieking in the gallery
being dragged out constantly.
How about this from Sheldon
WHITEHOUSE Mister white club
cut 18.
>> I
don't believe. It's factual
it's I don't believe the
Devil's triangle was a drinking
game. And I don't believe
calling yourself a girls alum
years this being her friend.
>> It was disgrace. It was one
of the worst things I've ever
seen in our politics in the
Washington Post editors have
the gall to try to tell us that
this week it was
far worse. On behalf of th